all right so today i'm going to tell you
about
burst timing dependent synaptic
plasticity and how it can coordinate
learning in hierarchical circuits um
this is something that those of you who
are at maine would have seen a
presentation on from richard no
but i will give a slightly different
light on it as well and
hopefully it will be new for you uh even
if you saw his talk
um so to begin with
uh if my
thing there we go okay i'm actually
going to
do most of this talk in a bottom-up
fashion
but i want to give you a sense of where
we're ultimately headed which is a very
top-down perspective
so the top-down perspective that i want
to give you is this
what does it actually mean to learn all
right
i think that it's important that we get
clear on what
we actually intend by this term
and i sometimes get frustrated in
conversations with people because when
we talk about
learning i feel like people have
sometimes a funny definition of what
learning is in their head
and so i want to get 100 clear on what i
mean by learning
so as far as i'm concerned learning
necessitates a normative perspective
and what i mean by that is that unlike
other changes that occur to your body or
your brain
learning necessarily involves changes
that we can
identify as being good or bad
because in order for it to count as
learning the changes that are occurring
must be
good they must be achieving some goal if
they're not
it's just changes so you can look at a
system that's evolving constantly
but we don't call it learning unless
there's actually some
metric that is provably getting better
as a result of those changes
and of course to quantify this normative
perspective in machine learning we use
loss functions
and i have argued that
neuroscience also needs to adopt loss
functions more for the record many
computational neuroscientists have used
loss or cost functions for their work
for ages
uh so it's not that it's new but
what i have been arguing for the last
couple of years
is that it's a perspective that needs to
be taken on not just by
a particular subsection of the
computational neuroscience
field but instead by the entirety of
neuroscience
and it's something that should inform
the way that we think about the brain
more broadly
now if we're measuring learning with a
loss function
whatever that loss function is and
we're restricted to relatively small
changes to our parameters
okay such that let's assume that we have
a smooth landscape
and the changes are small enough that
the function
is closest to linear in the
scale that we are potentially changing
things at
if that is the case then necessarily
if you get better at something over time
your changes must have been correlated
with the direction of the gradient of
that loss function
so if i have some synaptic weights at
time zero
and then they change to another set of
synaptic weights at time
t no matter what path i take to get
there
no matter what other changes are being
induced by other processes in the brain
if i actually call it learning this
vector of change cannot be completely
orthogonal
to the gradient of our loss function it
must be
at least non-orthogonal
and furthermore i would
venture the following which is that if
you are
measuring performance with a singular
loss function and we can talk later
about
the question of when you have multiple
loss functions which i think is very
interesting and relevant to the brain
but if you have a singular loss function
then generally algorithms
which adhere more closely to the loss
gradient
will actually tend to learn faster than
those that don't
now there are some exceptions to that in
terms of like you know obviously
you would ideally like things like a
second order method etc
but the direction is still going to be
along the direction of your loss
gradient
if instead you have an algorithm that
provides you an
estimate of the loss gradient but with
some variance or bias
learning is going to be slower and not
necessarily as good
an example of this comes from this paper
from zee and sung
actually this one might be worthless i
apologize uh
where they compare a standard gradient
method
to node perturbation and weight
perturbation the way that these
algorithms work
is you induce random changes in your
network
and then if the loss function goes down
you keep those changes if it doesn't you
don't keep them
and this could be implemented in a very
simple biological system and
to be honest i think it's how many
neuroscientists think
of learning in the brain but
these algorithms are providing you an
estimator for the loss function one
second i'll give you a call in a second
an estimator for the loss function with
high variance
and in fact the variance scales with the
size of the networks
such that you are always going to need
more data examples
to train up on our network with node
perturbation or weight perturbation than
with an actual
gradient based method yep
[Music]
so in fact what they did is in this case
they were
applying it to very simple networks
where they
could analytically calculate the scaling
with respect to the number
and i forget what the equations are but
they show that basically
it gets terrible with node perturbation
and wave perturbation
that's already too bad that's right
exactly
so um my argument then
which some people on twitter consider
ridiculous
uh
uh is that until someone demonstrates
efficient learning
in non-toy tasks without some kind of
reasonable estimate of a gradient
it's not crazy to start thinking about
potential physiological substrates
for gradient calculation in the brain
for some way of getting a hold on the
gradient to follow it as closely as
possible
yes sorry so so i i agree with that
point
what i should say here is that what we
want to see is information about the
gradient
that is relatively low
variance and not too biased
okay so this is where i'm going but what
i'm going to do is i want to start by
telling you
a story that's based on biology and
we're going to build up to gradient
destination
via a low-level biological model yeah
yes that's right because that's that's
because biologists don't understand
what the brain does generally uh
sorry what i mean by that is i i'm
joking
i'm a biologist i have a degree in
neuroscience and i've run many
experiments yes that's right
what yeah i'm channeling conrad i'm
joking around biologists understand a
lot about the brain
the reason that they push back against
this is because they imagine
that this is just us taking whatever the
shiny new toy is
deep learning and saying oh let's apply
this shiny new toy to the brain there
you go
we're going to solve it all for you you
poor biologists
who've been at it for decades that's
right
and it's very frustrating for them but
my point is that this claim that you
want to estimate the gradients
is actually a fundamental principle
about learning and so it's something
that still applies
even though deep learning might be the
shiny new bauble
in ai this fundamental idea dates back
way before the deep learning era and i
think has always in fact applied to the
brain
but because i'm aware of the fact that
biologists do actually know a fair bit
about the brain what i want to do is i
want to build this up from real biology
and so start with a model that's
grounded in real biology
okay so my talk today is going to
describe how this particular
plasticity rule that has been observed
in the brain which
i'll call burst timing dependence after
plasticity
coupled with some of the unique
properties of the dendrites of pure
middle neurons
can actually enable hierarchical
gradient calculations
okay so this is work that uh has been
done by uh
jordan gurgujiev a phd student in my lab
alexandre payer
uh postdoc in richard nozlab
richard himself and friedman zinke who's
now
at bristol
and this really has been a wonderful
collaboration richard said that at maine
and i really do emphasize that it's one
of
these
unique moments where like everyone's
just kind of working together and it and
it came together so nicely
um we should have a pre-print up by the
end of the month or
early january at the latest okay so
burst time independent plasticity
to start with you might have heard of
spike timing dependent plasticity or
stbp
i've got some unfortunate news for you
in case you like
stdp it's fake news scdp
is not actually a synaptic plasticity
rule in the brain
stdp is what you get in a very
particular experimental circumstance
when you control all these different
variables
just so there's a lot of evidence
and i mean a lot of evidence showing
that what really matters for determining
whether or not so for those of you who
aren't familiar sorry i should say
spike timing dependent plasticity or
stdp says that the sign of your
changes to your synapses should be a
function of the timing of pre and
postsynaptic spikes
so if you have the presynaptic cell
spike before the postsynaptic cell you
should get ltp
that's long-term potentiation that's an
increase in your synaptic strength
and if you have the opposite you should
get depression decrease in your synaptic
strength
but in fact what the biological evidence
is very clear on
is that the thing that determines the
sign of change
in your synapses in real neurons and i i
can say this is someone who's run these
experiments as well like
definitely the easiest thing that will
determine
what change you get in your synopsis is
how
depolarized your postsynaptic cell is
that is how
active your postsynaptic cell is and
in particular what matters is the
depolarization in the dendrites which
are the site of synaptic integration
now it turns out that the best way to
depolarize your dendrites
is with what we call a high frequency
burst
that is a set of multiple spikes that
occur in a high frequency train
in a row and what you can show in
experiments such as these ones here
so this is at the bottom um this is the
synaptic strength that that stands for
excitatory post-synaptic potential
amplitude so this is basically a
measurement of synaptic strength
for one neuron that connects to another
and they've patched on with electrodes
here to measure the synaptic strength
and manipulate the activity of these
neurons
and what they do is they ran this is a
study from let's get all from 2006 they
ran a protocol
where they caused the postsynaptic cell
illustrated with the blue electrode here
to spike just after the black cell
here so they cause the presynaptic cell
to spike and then they get the
postsynaptic cell to spike
and if you do this at a low frequency so
you go
up wait a few seconds
wait a few seconds you don't actually
get an increase in the synaptic strength
which is what spike time independent
plasticity says you should get
instead you actually get a depression in
the synaptic strength measured here
so that's this protocol here
in contrast if you now depolarize the
dendrites
of this cell in order to elicit
something called the plateau potential
which i'll tell you a little bit more
about in a second
and even this induces a high frequency
burst
you convert that decrease in your
synaptic strength to an
increase in your synaptic strength and
the reason is because that burst
really depolarizes the dendrites and
that depolarization is the key
biological signal that then
unleashes a biochemical cascade that
leads to an increase in the synaptic
strength
so let's model this basically is what
richard
i said yeah
so the reason the apical dendrite
matters and i'll come back to this is
because the apical dendrite is what
determines whether or not you get a
burst
but the same principle applies in any
dendrite the
plasticity is going to be determined by
the degree of depolarization if you get
just a little bit of depolarization
you get depression of the synapses and
if you get a lot of depolarization you
get potentiation of the synapses
you don't even need spikes in fact this
has been something that has been proven
multiple times over if you just directly
depolarize the dendrite and no spike
occurs
you get potentiation if it's high enough
and if you do it just
a bit you get depression because that is
the
biological signal yes
that's right yes exactly yep
the only thing that the presynaptic cell
matters for is it
must have been activated to see any
change occur
so people have shown that if you don't
have synaptic inputs and you just
depolarize the dendrite you're not going
to get any changes
it has to be that the depolarization is
paired with
a presynaptic input and we think that's
because the other key biological signal
is basically the the cascade that
emerges
from the neurotransmitter being received
at the at the site
there's effectively two things that need
to happen to get plasticity
by virtue of something called the nmda
receptor you need
some degree of depolarization at the
postsynaptic site and some presynaptic
inputs that will then give you
plasticity
yeah yes
that's right sprinkle on some glutamate
depolarize the dendrite
boom you got plasticity
stabilized yes
potentially that's right so let's come
to this
plasticity rule
so the way we model this is relatively
simple the idea is
that if you have a pre-synaptic input
whether it's a burst of spikes or a
single spike
the thing that determines whether you
engage in long-term potentiation that's
an increase in the synapse or long-term
depression decrease in the synapse
is whether or not the postsynaptic cell
is bursting
so if the postsynaptic cell is bursting
when you get pre-synaptic inputs or just
after you get pre-synaptic inputs
you get potentiation if it's not and you
just have an individual
spike you get depression and we model
that with this equation
so these are i should say at the start
here
everything i'm going to show you is
biophysical models we are explicitly
modeling membrane fluctuations and with
all the leaky channels and stuff
and we also have like continuous time
simulations of the synaptic weights so
what's happening is the synaptic weights
are updated according to this rule
their change is determined by of course
a learning rate but that's just a hyper
parameter for us
and these variables here so critically
bi here
is an indication of whether or not a
postsynaptic burst occurred
around time t so when a burst occurs you
get this
boolean variable saying yes a burst has
occurred yeah
a burst is a high frequency train of
spikes so
well that in this rule you need spikes
because we're not
modeling down to the level of an
individual synapse in the dendrite
so we are abstracting it the thing is
in vivo typically what's going to drive
depolarization
is spikes and bursts
now it doesn't have to be and there's
some situations where that's not the
case but
that's a good question here in this rule
yes you're going to need
a burst to get a change we're assuming
that this is the source of
depolarization
uh but what we're doing is we're not
just taking whether or not you get a
burst we're comparing
that we're we're scaling this effect
with a running average of the burst
probability and this gets to your point
so there is this stabilization effect
whereby
uh basically as you get more and more
bursts over time
the uh degree of
potentiation that you get decreases yeah
yes
it's not too different from it but there
will be situations in which the learning
rules
diverge because triplet stdp rules still
have
very complicated predictions about
specific spike trains that don't
necessarily match this one
but you're right they they're not
radically different in flavor
um ei here is just a measurement of
whether or not
a postsynaptic spike or burst occurred
and
the reason this gets included in the now
is let's say the postsynaptic cell just
spikes and it doesn't burst
what you now have is a negative term
here so you get
depression of your synapse
and then this is a presynaptic
eligibility trace which is basically
a sort of exponential uh kernel
that we uh convolve with the spike
trains
uh in order to determine when so when
presynaptic inputs have arrived in the
recent past
now yep
sure so
this is a hebbian learning rule in some
ways
it depends on what you classify as a
heavy and learning rule
so the the term heavy in learning has
both a broad and a narrow interpretation
the the broad interpretation is yeah
just presynaptic activity and
postsynaptic activity together determine
the sign of
determined potentiation or depression
the much more narrow idea is fire
together wire together
which says just that if there's
correlated activity between your pre and
post-synaptic cell you increase the
strength
regardless of the nature of that
correlation
here even if you have correlated spikes
you're going to get depression
you're not going to wire together it has
to be that the
presynaptic inputs are correlated with
postsynaptic bursts
now one of the things that we get out of
this so so when i said to you stdp was
fake news
an example of where it is fake is
so stdp says that if you have a
presynaptic spike followed by a
postsynaptic spike you could should get
potentiation
but the reality is that experimentally
you can see that that only actually
happens
if you do those pairings at a very high
frequency
so if you do pre post pre post pre post
at like 100 hertz you get potentiation
but if you do it at five hertz you
actually get depression
that's been shown experimentally and
indeed that's what happens with our
learning rule
the reason is that as you increase the
frequency
your train starts to become a burst and
so it converts into potentiation from
depression
we can replicate this basic experimental
result that was originally shown
by jesper shellstrom who's a researcher
here at mcgill now
and has been verified by many other
people so that that was nice to see
the other thing that's interesting is
that this produces something that looks
a lot like the beanstalk cooper monroe
rule for those
of you who are familiar with that that's
a rate-based rule
which says effectively that the
degree of potentiation or depression
should be determined by your
post-synaptic rate
and the other thing it has is a sliding
threshold for where you engage in
potentiation or depression based upon
your
recent history and pcm has been shown to
replicate a variety of biological
features
in terms of receptive field tuning and
stuff like that and
lo and behold what we actually get out
of running
a protocol where we do plus on spiking
with different rates
is the beanstalk cooper monroe rule it
just emerges out of the plasticity rule
okay so that's cool and like by itself
that would be a kind of fun
computational neuroscience study
but uh as you know i'm interested in
gradient calculations
so how are we going to get from here to
grading calculations
the way we're going to get there is
courtesy of the apical dendrites
okay so i mentioned earlier that the
april dendrites have special properties
that are
relevant to this question so for those
of you who are unfamiliar with them
pyramidal neurons are the
most common type of neuron in the
neocortex which is the region of the
brain that's concerned with kind of
higher order
functioning and
neocortical pyramidal neurons have this
interesting structure
where their cell body is surrounded by
one set of dendrites called the basal
dendrites
and then they have this big long branch
that they send off called the apical
dendrite that heads off towards the
surface of the brain
and then there's another set of
dendrites called the apical tuft
up towards the surface of the brain
and what's interesting is that
anatomical work has shown
that these two different sets of
dendrites receive
different inputs to a large degree now
it's biology so it's never 100
and let me just clarify that but
what we can say is that largely the
inputs to the basal dendrites
are coming from lower level areas so
they're going to be carrying information
about
what light is hitting your retina what's
touching your skin
what sounds you're hearing etc in
contrast top down feedback from your
higher order association areas
which are you know where you're forming
your
larger understanding of the world and
potentially your expectations for what
you should be seeing
those come into the apical tuft
and interestingly the
relationship between these apical
dendrites and the soma
is not what you'd typically think of
so normally we think of dendrites
receiving inputs and propagating it
through
to the soma in a passive manner
but that apical trunk is so long
it's electrotonically very segregated
from the soma such that when you get an
input to the apical dendrites
that input is not actually propagated
down to the soma
unless there's a non-linear event that
occurs which i'll tell you about in a
second
for that for for the passive propagation
that's shown here so these are these
experiments done
uh two decades ago now by matthew larkum
and they're they're really beautiful
experiments
i i cite this paper all the time
what he did is he patched the same
pyramidal neuron in three different
locations
color coded here according to the
electrodes and
he would give an input to the red
electrode here
and then look at how it came out at
these other two electrodes
and what you can see is if he just does
a passive propagation where he just
gives a little bit of input to the red
electrode
you can see it on the red electrode you
see it a little bit on the blue
electrode and by the time you're down at
the cell body which is where spikes are
generated
you see nothing so inputs from the
apical dendrite
when they're passively propagated
literally cannot reach the selma
but the way in which the apical tuft can
communicate with the soma is by virtue
of a set of non-linear calcium channels
that sit
in this trunk and these non-linear
channels
allow the apical dendrite to engage in
its own non-linear signaling not too
much different from a spike though
different in its temporal dynamics
which we call a plateau potential the
way this works is that when you
get sufficient depolarization of the
april dendrites such that it hits a
threshold basically
the calcium channels all open up and
when they open up
positive current flows into the apical
dendrite and they remain open for a
certain period of time
and this gives you this big
depolarization of the dendrite
seen in red here which lasts for quite a
long time
by virtue of the calcium channel
dynamics
we call this a plateau potential because
it lasts for a long time
and that plateau potential is propagated
down to the soma
in fact it has such a big impact on the
soma that it typically drives
bursts of high frequency spikes
so these plateau potentials are in fact
how you get
bursts and and the way you can think of
this is that they are in fact a
coincidence detector
so what happens is this is a biophysical
simulation done by adam shy
uh here we have a fully uh you know
multi-compartment simulation of a
pyramidal neuron and he's got
a synaptic inputs to the apical tuft and
synaptic inputs to the basal dendrites
and what happens is he shows that if he
drives inputs to the basal dendrites he
gets a single spike out of the cell
if he drives inputs to the apical tuft
oh
sorry what's going on there
it's bursting i know
if he drives inputs to the apical tuft
no spike occurs because it can't
propagate possibly
but if the apical tuft and the basal
dendrites are activated simultaneously
you can hit threshold in the apical
branch
that causes a plateau potential which
generates
your high frequency burst so the result
is
that inputs to the basal dendrites will
drive single spikes
inputs the apical dendrites do nothing
by themselves but if you get a pairing
of basal inputs
with apical inputs you get a high
frequency burst of spikes
now what this means for our plasticity
rule
is that now the inputs to the apical
dendrites become a teaching signal
effectively
because they're going to determine
whether or not your cell is bursting
so if you have two pyramidal neurons
connected where one parent melanon
connects to the
basal dendrites or the perisomatic
region of the other
and then you have some distal inputs to
the the
apical bend right here those inputs
are going to determine the sign of
plasticity at this synapse
so these are biophysical simulations
again so we've got a multi-compartment
model with voltages fluctuating and
all measured and simulated in continuous
time
and what happens is here we're showing
the probability of a burst in this
neuron
and as we increase input to the apical
dendrite
which is in the uh the
the red here we can see an increase in
the postsynaptic burst probability sorry
that
that is the post-synaptic first
probability which is resulting from us
increasing inputs to the distal output
if we decrease the distal inputs we
decrease the probability of getting a
burst
the result of these changes are if we
measure them at the weights
increases in the synaptic weights when
we increase the inputs to the apical
dendrite
and decreases in the synaptic weight
when we decrease the inputs to the
apical dendrite
so you've got this ability with your
apical dendrite to control whether or
not you're potentiating or depressing
in that yes it's on the apical trunk in
that paper
so no one's actually run these
experiments before this is a prediction
of ours that we're trying to convince
someone to run the experiments on yeah
yes like i'm saying i want someone to do
those experiments
very much so they're tough experiments
like
the way to actually do this properly
would require a lot of finicky things
so it requires someone committing you
know a phd students
a year of their life basically to
running these things so
it might take a while to convince
someone but i hope to
but then they get famous yes if it works
that's the problem
if they don't believe me then they're
not gonna try
so the experiment is you do a plasticity
protocol
from one pyramidal neuron to another
where you know the synapse is on the
basal dendrites
and then you simultaneously inject
current into the apical dendrites
and you should be able to show that you
can determine whether you get
potentiation or depression
by controlling the pull down right this
has been done
with multiple inputs to the april
dendrite and they've shown this
and the reason they do that is because
it's slightly easier because then
you've already got your patch on the
apical dendrites so the thing you're
injecting current with is also what you
can measure the synaptic
doing this experiment would require like
multiple patches on the same cell and a
plasticity protocol it's
difficult but do it
okay so the other thing that this
function of vehicle dendrites does is it
gives you
the ability to multiplex top down
and bottom up inputs this was something
shown by richard which is
it was it was how this collaboration
started
if you simulate an ensemble of pyramidal
neurons
that have these properties with
biophysical properties fit to
experimental data
and you inject current into the
perisomatic region
shown in blue here or the distal apical
dendrites shown in red here
you can show that what you end up
getting out are two different signals
out of the same spike train
now the way you can measure that is by
differentiating between events
and bursts i've already kind of
mentioned this but
the idea is that we define an event as
either
a spike or a burst and then
for any event you can ask was it a burst
so we can talk about across the ensemble
the
event rate that is how many of the
pyramidal neurons in the ensemble
are engaged in an event right now
simultaneously you can ask
what is the probability of bursting
across the ensemble and that's a
function of how many of the events are
bursts
so this gives you two dissociable
signals shown here
so as we increase the somatic input
we can see here we only get one event
out of across these three so these are
the voltages of three of the simulated
pyramidal neurons one two three
only one of the pyramidal neurons here
gave an event so our event rate is low
but that event was a burst so the burst
probability is high
we can get an increase in the event rate
such that here we have all three cells
giving an event so we have a high event
rate
at the same time as we get a decrease in
the burst probability
because fewer of the events are bursts
so these are two dissociable signals
that you can read out of the population
and what richard showed was that if you
look at
the inputs to the apical dendrite
and the somatic region if you just
measure the firing rate of the neuron
it's hard to see any sign of those
inputs it's just a bunch of noise
basically
but if you measure the event rate you
see
the inputs to the somatic region and if
you measure the burst probability
you see the inputs to the apical
dendrites so this means that
a group of neurons can be simultaneously
broadcasting
both what they're getting to their basal
dendrites and what they're getting to
their apical dendrites
this then means that you can in fact
propagate
top down and bottom up signals
simultaneously
so it requires a little bit more
machinery
involving some inhibitory interneurons
and it also requires
a particular assumption which we view as
another experimental prediction from
this model
okay uh which is that the bottom-up
synapses we did start late though but
oh you you got that okay very good
no you didn't it's one anyway oh but
you're giving me
uh very good so uh
what we have here is we're assuming that
the synapses in the basal compartments
and the inhibitory neurons that connect
to the basal compartments are driven by
what we call short-term depressing
synapses these are synapses that after
they've received one input
show a decrease in sub the response to
subsequent inputs
this is something we actually know from
biology that these synapses
are short-term depressing but there's
another set of synapses that you can see
in the biological literature which are
called short-term facilitating synapses
these are synapses where when you get an
input
it's actually very weak and you only get
a strong response to that input if it's
followed by subsequent inputs very
rapidly
and the difference between these things
is that these synapses are going to be
totally indifferent to bursts
whereas these synapses the short-term
facilitating ones will only care about
bursts
so if you assume that your bottom-up and
top-down synapses have these different
properties
and as i said we know these ones do yeah
there are evidence for that
so we know these synapses have
short-term depression
uh at their sites and in fact we also
know that the inhibitory interneurons
here have short-term facilitating
synapses
so three out of four of these synapses
have been demonstrated experimentally
the fourth one the top-down inputs have
not been studied
so it's an explicit experimental
prediction the top-down inputs should
have short-term
facilitating synapses
so it's a bit complicated to explain
here but basically
the interneurons are how you end up
dividing things out to get the signals
that you're actually interested in with
two different pathways
i i can show you later
you can have very few internals it
doesn't have to be a one-to-one matching
this can all be driven by just a single
internet it's just about controlling the
homeostatic level of the voltage
yes that's right that's right
um it's just normalization effectively
if you do this what you get is that
um when you have one set of pyramidal
neurons
receiving this sorry basal inputs and
another set of
inter pyramidal neurons receiving apical
inputs
so here we can see the apical inputs are
being driven by a slowly oscillating
current
the basal inputs down here are being
driven by a rapidly oscillating current
that rapidly oscillating signal will be
reflected both in the event rate of
these neurons
and the event rate of these neurons so
that bottom-up signal gets propagated
upward to the next set of neurons
simultaneously the burst probability in
these neurons
will it's also going to fluctuate with
the faster oscillation
but it will be amplitude modulated by
the slower oscillation coming from down
here
and so what that means is you now have a
signal
that is communicating this burst
probability from the top
which is dependent on the current you're
injecting into your apical dendrite
get communicated down to these neurons
at the same time as they're
communicating their event rate forward
so now you can have these groups of
neurons communicating bottom up and
top-down signals simultaneously with
each other
if we combine these two facts you can
actually do
hierarchical credit assignment using
btdp in pyramidal ensembles
continuing with the biophysical
simulation for a moment we do this very
simple
simulation because these biophysical
neurons like to clarify
you're all familiar with heavy compute
needs but
trust me you don't know heavy compute
until you've tried to simulate a
biophysical neuron
or thousands of biophysical neurons it's
a nightmare compute-wise so we keep this
very simple we have groups of pyramidal
neurons
arranged in ensembles like this with an
input layer a hidden layer
and an output layer and just uh what
we're going to do now is we're going to
train it on xor
so we're going to give inputs to the
bait the basal dendritic regions of the
two inputs
that match 0 0 1 zero zero one or one
one
and then we're gonna train these things
by providing a teacher signal to the
apical dendrites where we're gonna
activate the apical dendrites when we
have
one zero or zero one and not when we
have one one
or zero zero
this is what it looks like so before
training this is the output that we get
from the
output neurons at first it basically
just
gives low output when there's nothing
and then higher output when there's
something
and after training it's now learned to
step up its output
oh it's overall output is higher i
should say these are
there are biophysical reasons for that
but it has now learned
to step up its output to the one zero or
zero one cases and step it back down to
the same level as the zero zero case
when it gets one one and this was all
just by running this in continuous time
but and providing
these steps of current to the apical
dendrites here
at the times at the end of each epoch in
which we're showing a period of time in
which we're showing
the pattern to the inputs
these are just the error signals but i
in the interest of time i'm going to
skip through this a bit
okay yeah that's true
yes that's right what's the relationship
with the pipes
yeah so um it is important that you give
sufficient time for the activity to
propagate through the circuit
and then you need to also give a
pulse that the length of the pulse
doesn't actually matter
a super amount as long as there's long
enough for it to get to the hidden units
here
the hot the larger this network is the
the more time you'd have to give for the
teacher pulse so that it could propagate
down
it is timing sensitive yes
okay so
to actually get a hold on gradients what
we have to do is we have to zoom out to
the ensemble level
so the idea is that now we're not going
to simulate individual biophysical
neurons
we're going to instead treat treat each
ensemble of pyramidal neurons as a unit
unto itself and we're going to treat
those units as having
two different values an event rate and a
burst rate
the event rate is just a standard neural
network type input
it's sigmoid applied to linear
function we then have
the burst probability determined by this
is the feedback
of the burst rate from the higher layer
that's layer i plus one so i
here indicates layers and these are
vectors for the record
so this is the burst probability from
the upper layer
times the feedback synopsis and then we
also need
some homeostatic control over these
dendrites and i'll explain why in a
second
that's done with this negative z of the
burst rate of this layer here
and our burst rate is then just the
probability of bursting times the event
rate
so these are our units and
what you can show is that if you take
the limit
of an infinite size ensemble which is
obviously not how biology works but
it makes the math easier if you take the
limit of an infinite size ensemble
you get out a learning rule that looks
like this this is what burst time
independent plasticity turns into
in the infinite limit and what it turns
into
is the difference in the current burst
probability
minus a running average of the burst
probability
and then a heavy in multiplication of
the event rates
of the presynaptic that's the
presynaptic and postsynaptic
neurons and
that's our weight matrix update
so there's our current burst probability
moving average
and then our two event rates as i said
and you can show that if you make two
assumptions
now joshua also has another question at
main which which i haven't addressed
here which is
you there's also some considerations
about the nature of your activation
function here
uh which i'm happy to talk about
more in questions but the two key
assumptions are this
if you assume that your feed forward and
feedback weights are symmetric
and that your burst probabilities are in
a linear regime
then you can show that this is gradient
descent on a mean squared error loss
function
for a loss function where you're
receiving apical inputs at the top of
your hierarchy
now this is now why we use
these this feedback pathway that's to
get the linearity of our verse
probabilities yeah
that this learning rule is what that
learning rule turns into when you take
an infinite ensemble of
terminal neurons the limit of the other
one gives this
um now so what we do is we use this
pathway
because the burst probabilities have to
be between zero and one so we're
calculating those at the sigmoid
function
and in order to actually be following
the gradient we need that sigmoid
function to be sitting on the linear
part of the curve
we control that with a set of inhibitory
interneurons that are learning to
regulate the apical dendrites
homeostatically and keep them
in a kind of midpoint range and we can
show that if we can do
if we do that this is the difference
between our algorithm
the angle between our algorithm and
regular backdrop
in a network trained on mnist if you
don't train these weights you still get
some alignment because of something
called
feedback alignment which is a whole
other talk so i'm afraid i'm going to
have to leave that for now
but we can crunch down the difference
with the gradient even more by
linearizing those burst probabilities
shown in the red curve there
additionally you need to get feedback
weights that are symmetric
now it just so happens that there's a
simple algorithm for this
called the colin pollock algorithm which
we can adapt easily here because what
colin pollock basically just says is
that you
update your feedback weights with the
same update as the feed forward weights
plus some weight decay and because we
are updating the things just with bursts
which are available at synaptic sites
that's easy to postulate so so we
literally just update the feedback
pathway with the same updates
minus some weight decay and what you get
then is symmetric weights
and the result is that you're following
the gradient pretty well
so here's what you get if you train one
of our networks with just a feedback
alignment effect
shown in the green trace but if we add
this colin pollock stuff
and this is our burst time independent
plasticity rule
infinite limit rule that we're training
with
then you follow the gradient quite well
and on something like c410 you can
crunch it down to the same level you get
with back propagation
and we've been running this with a whole
variety of other data sets and
it looks like we can always match back
propagation
biology yeah so what it would require is
that the feedback synapses
are also changing according to the
difference between the burst
probability and a running average of
reverse probability
i need the sign of the feedback changes
to equal the sign of the
yeah so we can so what it what it
requires is that you're also paying
attention that's right to the
postsynaptic events and you need the
presynaptic
inputs
so the assumption is that the cell knows
what the other synapses are doing
in it it's not crazy
it's assuming that their biological
signals are shared throughout the cell
because it doesn't have to be
communicated across cells critically
okay i should finish up
uh this is the end anyway so
in general yeah i know
some species especially humans arguably
can learn many things very efficiently
and
i think one argument that i always find
amazing so so
i have discussions with biologists who i
respect immensely and who are incredibly
smart people like tony zador if you saw
him speak at maine
a while back a lot a couple weeks ago
tony's a
brilliant guy and he makes really cogent
arguments about
innate behaviors and he knows a lot
about the brain and all of these innate
behaviors that exist
and he's right that there are tons of
innate behaviors but then he makes this
falling leap he says okay there's tons
of innate behaviors
and so therefore i don't think learning
actually is something that matters
and it's that step that i don't get
because even if you have lots of innate
behaviors that have been
given to you by evolution any species
that
also developed on top of those innate
behaviors sophisticated learning
mechanisms
would totally out compete the species
that didn't have those sophisticated one
event
so arguably i think it's not
unreasonable to think that
evolution has endowed especially
generalist
mammals like us with
pretty good learning algorithms that can
learn very efficiently and
part of that as i articulated at the
beginning is to get
some way of estimating your loss
gradients that's going to give you
efficient learning
and what our work does is it provides a
proof of principle
as to how you can start with a
biological
learning rule and if you then
just add a few trappings to it you can
show
good estimation of gradients now
is the brain actually doing exactly this
algorithm
i have no idea that's something to be
determined by experimental testing
we've already discussed some of the
predictions that come out of this model
such as the short term facilitating
synapses at the
top down feedback uh
the the way in which the apical dendrite
would control the plasticity of the
basal dendrites
um and another example of a prediction
that our model makes is that
the variance inverse probability should
correlate positively with the error that
the
individual is making on some task
so what we predict specifically is that
you drop some electrodes in the brain of
an animal learning some
task when it makes errors you should see
increases not in the burst probability
but in the variance of burst probability
across
the cortex these are the sorts of things
we will hopefully convince
experimentalists to actually test for us
so ultimately what i argue is that we
should be doing top-down and bottom-up
simultaneously both in the brain
and in the field and that's that
thanks very much for listening